John first I gotta ask you do you
understand how famous you are right now
I'm beginning to alot of Hollywood stars
are out there battling now because they
want a part in the movie
and Tiger King the movie who do you want
to play you because people are
suggesting Shia LaBeouf No
nice fella buff Channing Tatum Channing
Tatum you want yes who should play Joe
deck oh yes deck or David Spade when I
first met Joe I was like a month out of
high school why did you shoot your
interviews with you sure all the
producers thought it would be something
that I'd like to do to show off tattoos
and stuff like that but he also
suggested it a lot of people were asking
why I did it without my shirt off it
wasn't about showing myself off or
anything it was just one of those things
where I felt like doing it so I did it
do you think the filmmakers were fair
with the way they portrayed everything
no they were not they made me look like
a drugged-out hillbilly they knit they
never showed the real new and improved
me mm-hmm
they showed me getting that's had to
cover it up but that was all they showed
me after that I'm waiting to give my
story out to be able to sit down with a
producer or a reporter to actually get
the whole story out and to really let
the world know what my life was actually
like who was the last time you had a
chance to talk to Joe I don't read not
talk to him if you could say one thing
to him was there anything you would say
to him or not I'd say Tim no nothing
nothing huh Wow
do you keep in touch with any of the
other folks from the GW Zoo no no
the end of the day the way this ended
are you happy now with your life and the
way you've moved on I'm absolutely happy
with how everything in my life has
changed and come out where you want to
go now now that you down you know you
you are living this different life and
so many people what do you hope for
yourself what do you want for yourself
still try and figure that out I mean I'm
in - I'm engagement love and since all
this has come to light I thought about
becoming an inspirational speaker or in
drugs abuse and things like that
[Music]